thing drops oh hang on this I actually
Blended the five and lost this is the
one thing you don't do 54 plate
King takes A3 which takes B6
yeah
so G3 will come
on little board update
looks like okay you can see on the big
screen where the port is a bit behind
now it's there
he just presents
eliminates the world champion Magnus
Carlsen in a dramatic
semi-finals what a game
by Duda
and yeah Carson
because won't be placed with how this
white game went
well yeah he
he chose a line that's I don't know
inherently a risky structure which has
been fashionable it's dangerous for
black but then he didn't measure put
enough pressure
while Doda just kept building his
position on the queen side had an
advantage throughout there were some
computer chances and we've talked about
yeah the moments where maybe Magnus once
again we are being helped by
by computers and chat of course where
maybe Magnus could have played something
more aggressive like here after okay to
A5 there was Pawn to H5 and then there's
A6 G4
later
there were some moments where he could
have gone for it